OK.
This is not the most important aspect of the
current situation that we're in.
I understand that, but I do believe it's worth
mentioning because there's a very important
media component to what is going on in our
country right now, not only with the protests
and the unrest and George Floyd, but also
with coronavirus.
This happened early with Corona virus and
it is now happening with all content related
to George Floyd protests, police brutality
and Tifa and even Trump's comments about these
things, YouTube and Facebook have completely
de monetized all of this content.
If you talk about one of the most important
issues facing our country right now, YouTube
and Facebook will demagnetize your videos.
Now, I want to be really clear.
This is not me crying censorship.
This is not me saying YouTube and Facebook
are doing something illegal.
This is me explaining to you how they are
making the wrong decision.
And this is how the soft suppression using
demonetization of newsworthy independent reporting
happens.
Now, I can talk about the fact that our country
is burning down as relations between citizens
and law enforcement completely break down.
I can talk about the fact that we have three
officers still not charged who were standing
there watching a fourth officer killed George
Floyd.
I can talk about how our president is failing
to lead and egging on police violence, but
we won't make any money from that.
And I'll have to figure out a different way
to pay staff and to do everything that we
do.
And believe me, I'm going to keep talking
about it because you need to know what's going
on.
And we can't leave it simply to corporatist
voices to tell you what it is that's going
on.
But this is very ugly.
It is tragic.
In fact, yesterday we did a ton of coverage,
of course, of George Floyd, the protests and
tangentially related topics, all demagnetized
on both YouTube and Facebook.
Check this out.
This is how important reporting gets suppressed.
So, OK.
Protests erupt and society breaks down.
That was a 15 minute segment.
I got a lot of compliments about it.
Spent all weekend researching how I wanted
to approach this demagnetized yellow dollar
sign, as you can see on YouTube, also demagnetized
on Facebook.
Trump threatening protesters with dogs.
This is a scandal.
Sorry, demagnetized on YouTube and Facebook.
Police victims or oppressor's?
Hugely important story.
Nearly ten minutes about how should police
departments and officers deal with what's
going on?
Is staying silent making one a part of the
problem?
This is a paramount issue deemed monetized.
Trump says he will designate and Tifa a terrorist
group.
This is a president misusing the State Department's
foreign terrorist organization list to suppress
American citizens due process and First Amendment.
It's a distraction from the real issues.
It's a totalitarian scandal.
Sorry, David.
Demagnetized.
And then, of course, our full hour show, the
full hour show which contains these stories.
Also demagnetized.
What are we doing, guys?
What is the point of all this?
What's the point of putting in the work?
And, you know, it's a really clever and great
way to Virtu signal to say we want people
dealing with important issues.
We don't want click bait.
We don't want low effort content.
Well, we spent all weekend researching this
stuff.
Violent and nonviolent protests, destruction
of property as a form of protest.
Historically, the six or seven different components
to the protest.
I mean, you know, we're talking about a ton
of staff time and it's just like now.
Sorry, our country is burning.
But if you want to monetize, what about a
Cardassian lying about being a billionaire?
Maybe talk about that if you want to monetize.
YouTube says we want to be part of the solutions
conversations.
We want to support creators.
Facebook supposedly the same thing.
But if you even tangentially touch the biggest
news story along with coronavirus, then no
ads are going to play.
You might remember this happened at the start
of Corona virus as well.
We were early on Corona virus.
We were covering it early, despite not only
the fact that a lot of people thought it was
overblown then, but despite the monetization
and we kept doing it after like a month, YouTube
realized this Corona virus thing might go
on for a while.
We can't just de monetize everything and they
started to monetize it.
This is how you nudge channels so that they'll
opt to cover, you know, some B.S. and more
and more of the coverage of what's going on
in this country.
The social unrest ends up being corporate
media and independent channels get pushed
away from it.
So we're not back.
Off today's show also, I mean, the entire
show is likely to be D Monitise, maybe there's
a one or two stories that won't be we are
not going to back off talking about it.
We have a crisis.
The crisis is that Trump's leadership has
failed.
We have major conflict when it comes to law
enforcement.
All of it needs to be discussed.
But this is how YouTube and Facebook are dealing
with it.
So know that if you want.
If you're able, you can support our work directly.
You're only about half of one percent of our
audience has memberships, but you can grab
a membership at join Pacman dot com.
If we can get from half of one percent to
one percent of our audience supporting us.
It's game over.
Right.
I mean, none of this stuff matters.
None of the demonetization matters.
So consider grabbing a membership at join
Pacman dot com.
You can get a 66 percent discount with the
code.
This is.
Don't feel obligated to use the discount.
Don't feel obligated to get a membership at
all.
We're we're going to continue covering this
stuff because it matters.
And it is it is once again, tragic that this
is how some of the major platforms where we
get, you know, millions and tens of millions
of views a month between YouTube and Facebook,
that this is the approach that they are taking.
It's sick.
We can fight it.
And, you know, even if you don't support me,
support some other show.
If you think some other show is doing better
coverage of this, by all means, support them.
But we have to make sure that independent
voices don't get sort of softly nudged away
from talking about this stuff, because then
it leaves just the corporate media outlets
talking about it.
We can't allow that to happen.